macht die dicke kohle den fußball kaputt
das ist eine frage die stellt sicher in
der bundesliga auch schon ein bisschen
länger der fc bayern münchen der ist ja
mit was das geld angeht ganz vorne dabei
und hat letzten saison zum siebten mal
in folge den titel geholt das finden
manche in münchen sogar jetzt schon
langsam ein bisschen lärm aber auch in
der champions league ist das so dass die
klubs mit der dicken kasse ganz oben
mitspielen heute ist auftakt der neuen
saison und da spielen zwei mannschaften
gegeneinander die haben beide viel geld
aber selbst da gibt es doch gehörige
unterschiede
das eine ist der bvb hatte im letzten
geschäftsjahr 2008 10 209 2009 10 einen
umsatz von sage und schreibe 490
millionen euro und da ist ja sogar schon
runter gegangen im vergleich zum vorjahr
und er tritt an bzw hat zu gast in
dortmund den fc barcelona und der hatte
einen rekordgewinn mal wieder in höhe
von 990 millionen euro also fast eine
milliarde umsatz
dann muss nur alte oma lange für kicken
würde ich sagen da ist jetzt die frage
was macht das mit dem fußball was macht
das mit dem sport mit dem spiel
das wollen wir heute diskutieren mit
euch und mit unserem zdf fußball
kommentar zions urgestein béla réthy der
steht für uns in dortmund ist uns dazu
geschaltet vor dem stadion
du wirst aber nicht kommentieren wähler
weil das zdf überträgt die champions
league ist schon in der zweiten saison
nicht mehr da sehe ich ein trauriges
lächeln auf dem gesicht was hast du
gedacht als du das erfahren hast dass
wir da quasi raus sind sind dass jetzt
die englischen verhältnisse das ist ja
normal dass pay tv anbieter solche
sachen übertragen
die war natürlich zu lesen war
enttäuscht aber das ist natürlich
einzelschicksale aber das ist der lauf
der dinge ist war damit zu rechnen dass
es nicht mehr bezahlbar sein wird aber
man muss natürlich auch sagen dass die
champions league dadurch einen massiven
verlust an reichweite hat die vereine
haben es inzwischen realisiert wird
jetzt beklagt dass ein free tv anbieter
fehlt genau diese zehn millionen
zuschauer die bei im schnitt hatten bei
unserer übertragung von 2012 bis 2016
die fehlen jetzt und auf einmal als auch
komisch dass er weniger leute gucken die
reichweite hat
klassen aber deutschland ist kein
klassisches paytv land sowie england zum
beispiel obwohl man da wenn man alle
sehen will um die hundert voll bezahlen
muss im monat
aber ich glaube der deutsche mensch ist
da nicht so bereit ob es ein urlaub zu
verzichten da machte er aber es ist
trotzdem schon ein signal sagte er in
richtung kommerzialisierung du hast
damit gerechnet ich habe damit gerechnet
weil irgendwann wir waren so in der
insel der seligen
das war die letzte bastion in europa und
die noch freie ausgestrahlt hat also von
den großen fußball ländern
aber es war es war klar dass irgendwann
mal wahrscheinlich vorbei sein würde
bilder also wie gesagt die die klubs
haben realisiert dass also
möglicherweise ein fehler war vielleicht
wird es noch irgendwann zurück gedreht
das rad ein bisschen zumindest gut das
schauen wir mal lasst uns erst mal
gucken was die fans zu diesem großen
komplex kohle und fußball sagen
lena hülsmann und andreas strobel haben
man ein paar stimmen für uns
zusammengefasst
fußball ist nicht mehr so wie er früher
war und geld spielt einfach eine rolle
weil mit geld wird auch
wettbewerbsfähiger das ist natürlich im
laufe der zeit dass ein wandel des
fußballs
es ist so schrecklich also ich sage über
das ist schon moderner menschenhandel
was da was da so abgeht also wenn es in
die dreistellige millionen summe geht
dann also habe ich da kein verständnis
mehr für ja gut daran denkt man jetzt
nicht so unbedingt als fan jetzt in dem
moment man freut sich trotz allem dass
man dann die guten spieler kauft und die
dann auch mal live sehen kann
stört uns gewaltig dass alles gespielt
wird da gibt sich verschiedene anbieter
und man muss sich alles kaufen oder
irgendwas damit man überhaupt alle sehen
kann wie man möchte
wenn man im münchner stadion ist sieht
man bei sky und sowas wird ja als teuer
und so was ich kann ja nur noch sky
fußball gucken zdf oder sowas ganz wenig
nur noch wiese auf länderspiele
die preise sind hart aber man geht
trotzdem für seinen verein aus liebe zum
verein und dass das überwiegt dann
trotzdem den finanziellen aspekt ja aus
liebe zum verein trotzdem sehr viel
kritik an dieser kommerzialisierung des
fußballs darüber sprechen wir mit béla
réthy der ist für uns in dortmund
erwartet ihn kennen als zdf fußball
kommentar zions urgestein der heute ist
champions-league-auftakt bvb gegen
barcelona und da interessiert uns
natürlich welcher effekt hat das ganze
jetzt auch den fussball sammelbilder wir
haben gerade ein bisschen gehört die
menschen müssen sich abos kaufen die
zahlen mehr eintritt was für einen
effekt oder welche konsequenzen hat das
dennoch für die fan-kultur oder für die
fußball fans also die stadien sind voll
die bundesliga ist gut besucht der
effekt wird sich nicht sofort auswirken
aber es wird eine große veränderung
statt hier natürlich war mal ein
volkssport für alle
das hat sich massiv verändert die
publikumsstruktur hat sich verändert und
nach england schaut man so ein operetten
publikum von von von leuten die wie sich
die logen dann leisten können also die
ganze die ganze also das ganze ambiente
hat sich komplett verändert
man fragt sich nur was man will
natürlich mein windmann wenn man diese
summen halt nicht bereit ist auszugeben
auf wie in deutschland zb da hat man so
eine geschlossene gesellschaft die für
sich lebt das kann hat ja auch ihren
reiz aber international muss man
befürchte auch den anschluss verlieren
wird man könnte jetzt aber doch sagen
gut das ist halt unterhaltung
unterhaltung kosteten musical ticket ist
auch ziemlich teuer dann geht man halt
nicht zum musical sondern um fußball
ja ja das könnte man natürlich sagen
aber wie gesagt es war der fußball ist
deshalb so populär weltweit weil er
seine einfache spiel ist von der
beispiel für die leute ist und das ist
natürlich völlig den bach runtergegangen
jetzt insofern die bundesliga ist
eigentlich eine fast löbliche ausnahmen
gibt es nur die die geringsten
eintrittspreise im europäischen
vergleich die liga in sich ist relativ
spannend dieses jahr vielleicht sogar
spannender als in den jahren zuvor
also man muss sich dann vielleicht
selber genügen und wenn man bereit ist
zu bezahlen das
ist im ruhrgebiet so ich will hier
hinterm ihren dortmund oder schalke aber
noch halbwegs bezahlbar das kostet da so
das ticket weißt du das nicht kannst du
das vergleichen mal zu england italien
frankreich also in asien zum beispiel
kurs sogar das achtfache von dem was im
bundesliga steht aufgerufen wird man
kann ihn in bayern münchen zurück sogar
noch auf dem relativ guten platz 17 für
50 euro das ist auch nicht geschenkt
aber ist immer noch bei 50 euro christen
england gar nichts viele arten wie den
chip vielleicht und noch ne dose cola
vielleicht oben drauf aber das
lieblingsargument vereine und verbände
ist ja immer viele einnahmen führen dazu
dass wir uns die stars kaufen können wir
uns noch gerade eben beitrag gehört
einer hat sich gefreut dass noch mal
dann die richtigen stars dann zu sehen
bekommt dass die bei einem verein
spielen
ist das nicht auch ein argument das war
die idee ist denn wenn man da das geld
nicht aus gibt dann hat man halt immer
nur noch die dritte und vierte wahl oder
das ist die frage der mentalität manche
länder akzeptieren diese summen in
deutschland ist ein bisschen schwieriger
aber ist ein dominoeffekt zum beispiel
barcelona hat ja damals hier dembélé für
100 millionen euro gekauft und das geld
hatten sie nur weil sie vorher für zwei
oder zwanzig millionen nehmer nach paris
abgegeben habe so ein dominoeffekt und
das führt dazu da ist das mittelmaß
immer teurer wird das werden wir nicht
nur für für das gelte auch für das
normale fußvolk institute die
abwehrspieler schon so teuer wie früher
die stürme also lieber puls van dyk hat
mehr als 80 millionen euro gekostet das
waren früher 5 millionen also das geht
nach oben also die armen werden
die reichen werden immer reicher die
abend allerdings auch allerdings führt
das dazu dass die schere immer weiter
auseinander geht
lena wir gucken meine kommentare hier
gibt es eigentlich nur kritik ich noch
niemanden gesehen da sagt eröffnet das
super bei facebook zum beispiel schon
mal drauf meint jutta daniel soli
niemand sollte einen bezahlsender buchen
sport schauen ist einfach nur noch
furchtbar geworden schämt euch ich weiß
jetzt nicht ganz genau wen du meinst mit
schämt euch
vittorio meint das nenne ich
volksverdummung und dann beklagen dass
ich finde dass die reichen immer reicher
werden die die sie für fußball
dann sind bezahlen tun genau das zum
glück ist mir die lust vergangen und
dann fragt das kann nie aussprechen
jayjay aus die tour liegend wann kostet
die fifa-wm eventuell auch noch geld und
gibt es das tatsächlich schon pläne das
auch eventuell die fifa wm nur noch im
pay tv ausgestrahlt ausgestrahlt wird
angeblich nicht aber ich will mir das
wort vielfalt und den mund nehmen da
traurig da keinem eigentlich genau über
dem weg die nächste weltmeisterschaft in
katar
die slow bei ard und zdf was danach ist
weiß ich nicht aber ich habe noch die
hoffnung dass ein verband der eigentlich
dafür da ist für die sache für die sport
da da zu sein dass sie auch die sportart
nicht gezielt kaputt macht das ist meine
hoffnung aber der fall schon ein bißchen
weiter
kann man denn sagen überhaupt das geld
die großen titel bringt also ist das ist
das so eine erfolgsgarantie möglichst
viel kohle rein punkten dann wird das
schon was gott sei dank ist es kein
automatismus
in der letzten saison hat ajax amsterdam
um ein haar das endspiel erreicht
natürlich wieder auch mit geld
gearbeitet habe ich habe eine großartige
akademie also die waren im halbfinale
und die die reichsten nämlich paris und
manchester city noch gar kein idiot in
der champions league also es gibt immer
noch gewisse hoffnungen dass man durch
sportlich intelligente entscheidungen
wenn durch clevere scouting eine gute
jugendarbeit möglicherweise da mithalten
kann da wird natürlich aber immer
schwieriger
das heißt das geld reinpumpen es eher
eine kurzfristige lösung und nicht so
richtig nachhaltig das kann nachhaltig
sein aber es ist nicht zwingend also man
man sagt ja ich war neulich bei der
dokumentation auch irgendwann bei dem
klub er sagt auch klar wir haben
investoren wir haben geld aber wir haben
auch die besten trainer im lande also
eher inclusive paket enovia die ola die
aber der bessere trainer ausbildung auch
also also bei uns geld allein ist es
nicht also sie schon know how gefragt
scouting vernünftige ausbildung also
dass ein gesamtpaket weil das geht
natürlich schon eine wichtige rolle
spielt das heißt du gerade schon
angesprochen in england gibt es vor
allem investoren da gehören klubs gleich
zum beispiel ganzen ländern oder oder
ganzen investoren das heißt das ganze
ist in privater hand
das ist bei uns nicht möglich durch die
so genannte 50 plus 1 regel die auch
immer wieder angegriffen wird kannst du
dir mal ganz kurz für alle die die nicht
kennen zusammenfassen
das heißt also ein anteil also über die
50 hinaus dem verein gehören muss das
heißt also ein investor hat nicht die
chance ein verein komplett zu kaufen wie
in england zum beispiel der fall ist
diese regel wird immer wieder diskutiert
ob man davon abstand nehmen sollte in
deutschland
aber gerade hier zum beispiel borussia
dortmund etwas gesagt schlimmste was dem
deutschen fußball passieren könnte wäre
wenn man seine unabhängigkeit aufgibt
und verliert und irgendwelche dubiosen
personen aus dem arabischen russische
chinesische und sonstigem raum jeder
sage haben da wäre dafür seien
allerdings wirklich auf einem falschen
wege
da gibt es andere die sagen wir werden
wie julian wißmann neulich irgendwann
nicht mehr darum herum kommen diese 50
plus 1 regel aufzuweichen
um international konkurrenzfähig zu sein
ergebnis da an der methode dass solche
idee fell oder dw die investoren auf
seriosität prüft und wer vielleicht also
ein kompromiss möglich
irgendwann wird das glaube ich kommen im
moment ist noch nicht so weit aber ich
glaube
demnächst wird das wie wertvoll ist so
eine regel wenn man die im grunde auch
hacken kann ich meine wir haben mit rb
leipzig einen verein wenn ich richtig
informiert bin hat er 17 mitglieder dass
das ist in deutschland kann man ja
sobald man fünf leute zusammenhang an
den verein gründen das heißt im
endeffekt ist dann ja dieser gedanke
auch total aus hebel bar oder wenn drei
deutsche sie trifft die grünen die ihren
verein aber das ist natürlich ganz
clever gemacht
die statuten lassen dass so das ist eine
clevere konstruktion der verein ist
eigentlich prinzip nur gegründet worden
und
um eben diese die den sponsor da aus
salzburg ein bisschen ist licht zu
rücken wo wir das konzept von leipzig
schon sehr gut ist also die könnten mit
dem geld
messi und ronaldo und nehmer und alle
gleichzeitig kaufen das tun sie nicht
die setzen auf eine auf einer ausbildung
auf jugend aufeinander auf der ganz
klare strategie also es ist nicht nur
der reinen kommerz also ein bisschen
differenzieren so wir gucken noch mal in
die kommentare hier was unsere zuschauer
zu schreiben also jetzt tatsächlich auf
youtube von samuel die einstellung
fußball ist nicht mehr das was es mal
war wobei ich mich manchmal auch frage
wann war es denn das was es mal war ich
meine das ist doch auch schon ein paar
jahrzehnte her bilder oder dass man
sagen könnte das war noch der ak fußball
wo es noch keine sponsoren gab älteren
wie ich ist 90 mal so ein spiegel heft
die hand gefallen 1963 zur gründung der
fußball bundesliga
da hat das magazin aus hamburg getitelt
und macht geld dem fußball kaputt diese
diskussion ist ziemlich alt und
natürlich waren profifußball über
privilegiert und habe immer mehr geld
verdient als ein automechaniker oder aus
dem klempner also die die relation haben
sich ein bisschen verändert diese zahlen
sind völlig absurd inzwischen aber
kommerziell war der fußball eigentlich
immer schon das muss man sich auch mal
noch mal sagen lassen
es gibt ja versuche das ganze
einzudämmen financial fair play heißt
die initiative der uefa und was das
genau ist das erklärt uns jetzt jochen
spieß mal 139,5 und 90 euro so die
unverbindliche preisempfehlung für den
spiel bei der neuen
champions-league-saison
die spiele der königsklasse live schon
länger nur noch im bezahlfernsehen zu
sehen
die champions league ist eben auch
spitze im geld machen
die einnahmen der uefa beliefen sich zum
ende der saison 2008 10 auf 2,1
milliarden euro
drei viertel davon mit
übertragungsrechten das meiste geld
davon fließt an die vereine
wer als mannschaft dabei ist braucht
auch jede menge geld um mithalten zu
können faix oligarchen oder solvente
getränkehersteller haben schon einige
vereine finanziell fit gespritzt solche
klubs aus manchester oder paris können
sich dadurch transfers von über 100
millionen euro pro spieler leisten
der fc bayern hat sich zumindest in zwei
teuersten vom fc barcelona für ein jahr
ausgeliehen
doch selbst der usa wurde es mit den
millionen geschäften der vereine zu viel
sei 2013 geht das financial fair play
dabei wird vor allem das verhältnis von
einnahmen und ausgaben eines vereins
gecheckt beide seiten müssen über die
jahre einigermaßen ausgeglichen sein
das geschäftsmodell darf nicht nur von
den riesigen investitionen eines mit
sense abhängen trotzdem wurde wohl bei
sponsorengeldern leihgeschäften oder dem
kauf von spielern hierunter getrickst um
die offizielle gegenrechnung sauber zu
halten
bei verstößen drohen allerdings hohe
geldstrafen punktabzüge oder der
ausschluss von spielern oder des ganzen
vereins der große ac mailand darf er in
dieser runde nicht auf europa ebene
spielen weil der die letzten jahre zu
viele schulden machte
doch manche finanzexperten sehen
financial fairplay skeptisch weil
investoren so nur begrenzt geld in
kleinere vereine pumpen können dadurch
scheffelten in europa er die
erfolgreichen klubs mit den dicken
bilanzen weiter das große geld ja viel
kritik auch hier bei euch immer noch in
den kommentaren hier schreibt er reif
auf facebook 50 plus eins ist gut haben
wir gerade erklärt die regelung in
deutschland aber somit bleibt man
international kaum konkurrenzfähig ich
bin da ehrlich gesagt zweigeteilt und
jefferson schreibt auf youtube selbst
wenn der fußball durch vielfach stärker
reglementiert wird die neuen regelungen
werden entweder wissens maximum verzehrt
oder es gibt hintertür treffen
die kennen wir von der fifa und von der
uefa leider mittlerweile béla réthy ist
für uns in dortmund wird sich nachher
das champions league auftaktspiel bvb
gegen barcelona angucken und wir
diskutieren über die frage geld und
fußball wie passt das zusammen
die haben gerade gehört verein stellt
fairplay bela was hältst du von dieser
ganzen idee eine prima idee wie sie
umgesetzt würde im sinne des erfinders
aber es wird natürlich immer wieder
umgangen also zb thema wird ja gar nicht
von paris bezahlt heißt es sondern von
der katarische stiftung er ist ja
praktisch wm-botschafter 2022 als man
umgeht das permanent jetzt hatten wir
mal ac mailand man großen klub erwischt
ansonsten als immer nur vereine aus
rumänien kroatien oder kleine spanische
klubs in malaga getroffen an die großen
geht man nicht kann man konkurriert
damit starten mit den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten besitzer von
manchester city oder mit katar besitzer
von paris und da gibt es allein die
tatsache dass katar die welt was ich
auch bekommen hat mit der schlechtesten
bewerbung von allen kandidaten spricht
dafür dass der andere kanäle im
hintergrund viel größere markt haben
also sogenannte regularien die ganz
halbherzig nur verfolgt werden also eine
gute sache die aber nicht umgesetzt wird
gibt es denn eigentlich überhaupt keine
gegenwehr bei den kleineren mittleren
verein ich meine wenn man so nah in den
osten gucken international ist ein
osteuropa gar nix mehr los
die haben ja quasi nichts mehr zu melden
gibt es niemanden ich meine
wirklich hunderte von vereine in der
uefa die sagen leute das geht so nicht
mehr ich habe keinen bock dass nur noch
die big three das ganz unter sich
ausmachen
die uefa wird im prinzip über die große
klubs auch reguliert also die ganze
reform der champions league werden ja in
geschlossenen zirkeln der großen klubs
im prinzip gecheckt und sofern die
champions league reform steht ja auch
noch andere angeblich mit acht der
gruppen werden jetzt diskutiert da haben
nur die große kluft das interesse da das
geld zu vermehren
da sehen die kleinen einfach überhaupt
froh dass sie mitspielen dürfen also die
chance haben wieder 0
hier gab es eine schöne frage sie haben
auch gefallen das war nochmal von ralf
tatsächlich auf facebook der meint
schlimm finde ich die entwicklung dass
nun bald dort die champions league am
wochenende stattfinden sondern somit die
bundesliga verdrängt dann werden auch
den amateur plätzen noch weniger
zuschauer da sein
leider ist das tatsächlich so was wähler
dass der amateurfußball da im endeffekt
runter leidet oder geht es da nicht auch
eine gegenbewegung dass menschen sagen
okay ihr mit euren 800 euro tickets
können uns mal wir gehen jetzt wieder
die vierte liga gucken
das war weiß so viel früher als die als
die dl eine geschlossene gesellschaft
wurde als die klubs plötzlich
irgendwelche tiere nahmen bekamen
amerikanische tieren haben und man
dachte dass die qualität dadurch besser
sein würde
oder sind die eishockey fans auf die
dörfer gefahren bartels oder oder oder
landshut vielleicht gibt es aber im
moment ist die champions league gewinnen
der kein diskussionsthema mehr angeblich
ist das vom tisch also zumindest da wird
die bundesliga oder amateurfußball
verschont aber ich glaube auf diese
ganze höchsten stopp bei der
feinkostabteilung da wird nicht darüber
nachgedacht wie schienbein 07 am sonntag
lagen um mit dem leben
es ist schön zusammengefasst den gab's
noch eine frage aus der zuschauerschaft
ihr wollt ich habe findet den kommentar
leider gerade nicht aber die ging in die
richtung kann man gegen die macht des
geldes überhaupt noch ankommen oder ist
der drops gelutscht und wir müssen damit
leben wie es ist
wir müssen damit leben wie es ist der
fußball an sich ist nicht schlechter
geworden wie qualität der spieler der
viele an sich ist durch die champions
league natürlich gewaltig gestiegen also
früher in den 70er jahren
solche murks begegnungen also der
fußball an sich hat sich ja nicht
verschlechtert
die rahmenbedingungen sind natürlich
suboptimal und dass die popularität
dieser sportart allein wenn man sieht
wie zb das ist paris auch eine
unterhaltungsindustrie daraus machen
will mit eigenen modelabel pipapo
nebenbei hat 125 millionen follower auf
instagram ps entspricht der bevölkerung
vor japan ungefähr also das rad ist
nicht mehr zurückzudrehen weil durch die
popularität einfach natürlich alle daran
partizipieren wollen und geld regiert
die welt ist platt heime böse wahrheiten
abschließend wurde auch hier auf youtube
nachgefragt dein tipp hier wurde sogar
gefragt wer gewinnt die champions league
klappt so weit nach vorne wachst du dich
jetzt nicht aber tipp für heute abend
hat dortmund da überhaupt eine chance
gegen barcelona eine ganz realistische
messi sitzt auf der bank ist erst einmal
wieder dass er dabei ist also schon mal
im vorteil
und auch ziemlich viel bei dortmund paco
alcacer in barcelona kann mir gar nicht
zurecht er ist ganz heiß zurzeit der
beste torjäger beim bvb also ich gehe
mal von einem 2 2 1 von dortmund aus gut
da hat sich jetzt unser zdf
fußballexperte béla réthy einmal
festgelegt 2 2 1 gegen den bvb wir
werden das in einer für den bvb
tschuldigung das werden wir in ein paar
stunden wissen
ich bedanke mich jetzt aber erstmal bei
diabetes durch einen schönen
fußballabend und bedanke mich bei euch
für eure fragen und kommentare zu dem
thema wir sehen uns wieder im nächsten
leben am donnerstag 20.30 hier auf den
gewohnten kanälen wir bespielen gab auch
gerade eine frage auf periskop gibt es
kein teleskop scream er doch gibt es
weiter wir bespielen wirklich alle
plattformen die wir finden können
facebook youtube periskop und die zdf
mediathek natürlich auch und die heute
de startseite
da könnt ihr uns finden bei twitter sind
wir nicht wir sind ja keine gamer so
aber das war es jetzt für heute wir
sehen uns bis bald und tschüss
so und wenn euch dieser stream gefallen
hat dann gefällt aber ich vielleicht
auch das hier
da haben wir über das feindbild suv mit
dem youtuber matthias malmedie
gesprochen oder über diesen stream könnt
ihr vielleicht auch euch freuen da geht
es um in game verkäufe und die frage ob
blut boxen verboten werden und natürlich
verboten werden sollen und natürlich
wenn ihr bock habt uns öfter zu gucken
denn keinen live stream zu verpassen
nachrichten aus der heute redaktion zu
kriegen dann einmal hier lang da geht es
zum abo button und ansonsten immer
fleißig licon daumen hoch und
kommentieren wir freuen uns